welcome to another thankful thursday i
believe it's important to thank the
people in your life who've had an impact
on you and your business you can't do it
alone and so it's nice to every now and
then just say thank you so today i want
to thank dylan powell dylan works for an
organization called enactus part of what
enactus does every year is run an annual
competition to support student
entrepreneurs and dylan recently reached
out to me asking me if i would come and
be a judge it's all about believing in
entrepreneurs so of course i said yes
and i was blown away by the size of the
event and the energy and enthusiasm that
was there i got to meet a lot of young
entrepreneurs who have big dreams to go
out and change the world if the future
of our country is in their hands then i
look forward to seeing what this country
is going to come up with and
organizations like enactus are not
possible without amazing hard-working
staff like dylan dylan and his entire
team poured their heart and their soul
and their sweat into making this event a
huge success and had a huge impact on a
lot of young student entrepreneurs it
helped them believe in themselves and
i'm sure gave them a lasting memory that
they'll take with them for the rest of
their lives so dylan thank you so much
for the invite and for everything that
you do at enactus and for those of you
watching take some time today to say
thank you to somebody who's had an
impact on your business or in your life
send an email make a video take them out
for coffee doesn't have to cost you
anything just take some time to
recognize them and say thank you it'll
make them feel great and make you feel
great you'll be spreading tons of great
karma out into the world and it's a
fantastic way to close your week and
remember
believe for those of you watching like
this video you can subscribe to the
channel thank you so much for watching
and i'll see you soon
i'm calvin moyer i'm a singer songwriter
and radio personality i subscribed to
evan's newsletter a few years ago it has
really helped me
the newsletter is very informative and
inspiring and it has helped me
throughout my career so i encourage you
to don't give up you can make it
subscribe to evans newsletter today
you won't regret it
you